What I'll do next is to give you
another programming assignment.
Rather than printing out the particles themselves,
I want you to print out the overall
quality of the solution
and to do this, I've programmed for you an "eval" code
which takes in as a robot position
and a particle set,
and it computes the average error
of each particle, relative to the robot pos
in "x" and "y"--not in the orientation.
And the way it does it, it basically compares
the "x" of the particle with the "x" of the robot,
computes the Euclidian distance
of these differences, and averages all of those.
So it sums them all up
and it averages them, through the
number of particles over here, which is upper caps N.
Now, there's some funny stuff over here.
The reason is, the world is cyclic
and it might be that the robot is at 0.0 or at 99.9.
It's about the same values
but, according to this calculation over here, they'd be different.
So while there's normalization over here,
I make sure that the cyclicity of the world
doesn't really affect negatively
the estimated error I've enclosed in the boundary.
You might parse this.
I'm adding "world_size" over to
the computer model operation and then
subtract the same thing over here--I can't even see it.
It's just too long a line.
Be that as it is, I want you to take the function, "eval",
and produce a sequence of performance evaluations.
And if we hit the run button,
I want you to produce something like this stuff over here:
4.9, 3.6, 2.9, 2.8, 3.1.
This is the residual error.
Remember, it's a world of size 100 by 100,
so this is actually a relatively small error,
compared to the world's size.
Can you code it so I get, for each iteration,
the error number produced by this routine over here?